the watchman universe is actually I mean
obviously hugely important to
development comic but is coming back now
in the DC rebirth they've been hinting
at the appearance of dr. Manhattan as
villain I would like the question to
long as all I'm gonna say is no comment
no they didn't Wow Wow and that's all
I'm gonna say hey you were about you
were a consultant on Zack Snyder's what
yes also the architect behind kind of
like the DC Marvel DC universe universe
and stuff do you think that with the new
watchman books and stuff and what's been
characters obviously going on new rights
commode that we can see an expansion of
the watchman's universe we have Snyder
behind it and as someone who's worked
with him do you think he's the filmmaker
who could really do it justice well I
think Zack Snyder
or Zack as I called is there is a very
talented filmmaker and I thought what he
did with Watchmen was about as good as
anybody could have expected to do and he
put a lot of time into a lot of passion
he had complete understanding of the
material he was dealing with now he's
really happy with that
that movie it's a flawed movie nothing's
perfect but I really thought they gave
it the real proper try and I feel that
the what's happening now with the DC
characters in film to my mind is going
in the wrong direction I did a panel
earlier on I was talking about films
that influenced me what Marvel seems to
have done is take their characters with
their dark side and their light side in
their humor and their pathos and their
human emotion and they've actually had a
long vision of what they're going to do
they put together films that are really
entertaining that are exciting that do
have threatened jeopardy but have humor
and a human quality to them and a sense
of hope but I feel that what DC has done
particularly with the Superman versus
Batman movie
is they really have taken a misstep on
it I mean I wrote a comic book called
world's finest rich was Superman versus
Batman I'm what I hunting and I'm not
saying this is the only take but it
might have helped was you know you've
got Batman who is a dark hidden creature
who lives in a dark evil city whose
antagonist is a brightly colored clown
you've got Superman who is a brightly
colored figure he's yang if you like to
the to Batman's you he lives in a bright
hopeful City but with a villain with an
opponent who is a dark grey scheming
businessman so the whole universe is a
completely complementary so it's a
complete when I write my story I got got
a lot of mileage out of just crossing
those over and and it turned out that
Luthor went to Gotham and the Joker came
to Metropolis and the Joker wanted to
black out metropolis and Luthor wanted
to sing set Gotham on fire so to me if
you doing Superman versus Batman the
first thing which is implied by the
verses is there has to be a difference
and I think that where the latest film
suffered was because they would just
both these dark opaque angsty creatures
I thought though I would have to say
that Ben Affleck's Batman was brilliant
I thought if people in the Batman film
what film on his own I also think DC
sort of lost their nerve because
Superman versus Batman which is
basically Frank Miller's Dark Knight's
story is enough for a movie without
putting doomsday in it which is another
complete Superman movie without
shoehorning the flash and the cyborg and
the book and without Wonder Woman she's
a movie in it in her own right you know
I as I say I'm I'm perhaps perhaps at
the moment I'm I'm less than a hundred
percent thrilled about DC but I wouldn't
want to be in every book and I certainly
I'm not coming down down and on Zack but
I come to my taste they kind of missed
mr. Traylor
I think also Marvel have been very bold
that they introduced the characters
slowly so when they put them all in the
movie together it gave me that same
thrill as I had with a kid when they put
all their characters into the Avengers
oh all the among comic and the ladies
Captain America movie you know the Civil
War the bit where there two teams run
run towards each other with all their
powers blaze we just oh yeah this is
what comics are about so I think Marvel
have done it with verve and wit and DC
kind of missed out on that
you